ladies and gentlemen welcome to another
episode where i keep my hair today we
have throwback thursdays hope you have
something to drink uh something a little
stiffer
because we're talking about a very
serious topic today
napoleon hill guys this is uh sort of
the moby dick
of gurus he's the big white whale that
most people don't even know is lurking
under the surface he's influenced
more business gurus than you could
probably imagine
in fact tony robbins it's one of his top
five books of all time
uh he's influenced dan lok have you read
the book
tai lopez have you read this book bob
proctor
you see this is the first book i ever
read think and grow rich by napoleon
hill i'd never read a book before that
chances are if you have a business guy
you follow he's read napoleon hill
and he thinks he's the absolute just
listen to this youtuber summarize sort
of the popularized
story of napoleon hill what's going on
guys
as many of you know one of my favorite
books in personal development is think
and grow rich
that book was catalyzed as a result of
napoleon hill the author
meeting andrew carnegie who was the
wealthiest man in the world at the time
carnegie basically charged napoleon hill
with interviewing a number of successful
people almost 200 people
and extracting the principles that
allowed them to do their life's work
right that's pretty amazing actually you
have this guy who was broke
at the time napoleon hill a journalist
apparently
who got allowed into the inner chambers
of andrew carnegie for a long three-hour
interview
and he ends up basically committing
napoleon hill with his most important
work
passing down his knowledge napoleon hill
repeats the same story
when i first heard andrew carnegie
describe this natural law which makes it
possible for you
and i and everyone else to write his own
price tag in life and attain it
my search led me to the study of the
spiritual forces with which all
of us are blessed and it was in this
field that i came upon a cliff
entertainment
while i was being coached by andrew
carnegie during the organization of the
science of success philosophy
i had just finished telling mr carnegie
that i feared he had
chosen the wrong person to give the
world the first practical philosophy of
personal success
because of my youth my lack of education
and my lack of finances an incredible
american story
of somebody from a high billionaire
business class
reaching down and lifting someone up who
is an unknown writer to pass on his
greatest wisdom
except it probably never happened
[Music]
okay so why do i say that how could i
claim
that this man whose entire life's work
is built off of this
incredible chance meeting with andrew
carnegie passing down all his
information
how could i claim that he did not meet
him well for starters
they apparently met early in the 1900s
but he didn't start telling the story
until after andrew carnegie died he
didn't share the story that they had met
together
and the proof of andrew carnegie
actually meeting with him
well apparently he had all their letters
together but uh
according to his own biographers they
got lost in a fire
unfortunately all the letters yeah they
burned away
now at this point i'm getting a little
bit of evan luth revives
if you guys don't know that's someone i
interviewed before who claimed he was
mentored by steve jobs was he your
mentor or not let's just answer that
question with yes or no
i think i would like to say yes later
when i pressured him on this he admitted
that actually
he had never talked to steve jobs at all
and instead he
mentored in the sense of he had been
inspired by steve jobs i have a little
trouble believing that because
on our call i think yesterday you said
you were not mentored by steve jobs and
that you never said that
i never said steve jobs was a mentor by
the way it doesn't you don't have to
talk to somebody all the time to
consider them your mentor
i would like to believe that the
internet has been my biggest mentor
that's kind of like napoleon hill it
seems because
there's absolutely no evidence that he
ever met with andrew carnegie
even if you believe that it was lost in
a fire we can compare
napoleon hill's writings about andrew
carnegie with andrew carnegie's own
writing
in fact andrew carnegie's own biographer
doubts that they ever met at all
he says let me put it this way i found
no evidence that the book was authentic
so this man built an entire career on
this alleged meeting of the minds with
andrew carnegie and all these
wealthy people but there's no proof of
it and andrew carnegie's own biographer
says
yeah it didn't happen but guys we can
reach deeper than that we don't have to
simply rely
on this guy's opinion who is he just the
biographer of andrew carnegie
so we have two books we're gonna look at
one is napoleon hill's account of his
conversation with andrew carnegie and
two
we're gonna actually look at andrew
carnegie's biography and we're gonna
look at
one of his little mini books called the
gospel of wealth
see andrew carnegie actually wrote a lot
despite what these ideas say that andrew
carnegie needed a reporter
to transcribe all his ideas down for a
guy who was gonna let someone else do
the talking he sure wrote a lot
so let's compare these two in napoleon
hill's account of andrew carnegie
carnegie comes across
like he's really doesn't really feel bad
for people who are poor because really
there's no injustice because just like
the law of attraction states which
of course i think you guys should know
by now is what napoleon hill came up
with and think and grow rich you guys
don't know
that's what the secret was based off of
that's where all this stuff is inspired
by
but he says here understand this truth
and you will note that there's no
injustice in connection with the
difference between the fortunes which
men
accumulate in other words whether you're
andrew carnegie or you're the guy
working at mcdonald's
you deserve what you get they are where
they are and they are drawing the wages
they receive
solely because of the limitations they
have set up in their own minds in other
words look
everybody could be rich look literally
everybody
there's no problem with that you just
have to think about it it's your mindset
your mindset's bad
have you heard of that but according to
andrew carnegie who sounds much more
like a businessman than a self-help guru
in his own book
gospel of wealth he says that
competition naturally creates inequality
under the law of competition this
employer of thousands is forced into the
strictest economies
among which the rates paid to laborers
figure prominently
and often there's friction between the
employer and the employed between
capital and labor between rich and poor
sounds a little bit different right and
wait a minute that completely conflicts
what napoleon hill says over here i
never set
the wage scale of any man who works for
me that's supposedly andrew carnegie
right there talking
right there you see that but andrew
carnegie in his own book
laments the fact that he's forced to pay
the strictest economies basically the
lowest possible rate
for the most amount of work which is how
capitalism works
you want to pay as little as possible
for the best amount of work and then
competition is foreign for who you can
hire based on that
additionally it is categorically false
that andrew carnegie ever thought that
everybody could just be rich by thinking
that way he thought instead
like a business person would think that
people who excelled at things of scale
would inevitably make more money than
people who didn't in other words if you
can own
the cloth factory you can make more
money than the person who sells the
cloth or creates the cloth one by one
there must be great scope for the
exercise of special ability in the
merchant and in the manufacturer who has
to conduct fares on a great scale
that that this talent for organization
and management is rare among men
is proved by the fact that invariably
secures enormous rewards
for its possessors in other words either
andrew carnegie completely changed his
beliefs
by the time he talked to napoleon hill
and between when he wrote this book
or somebody's lying here so what else do
we know about napoleon hill that could
push us one way or the other does he
have a pattern of lying
or is he telling the truth well i'll let
you decide from some of his incredible
stories
according to him president wilson even
though he was broke
decided he wanted to put all napoleon
hill on the government payroll at a
rather attractive salary now
how did he meet president wilson well
apparently of course andrew carnegie
really wanted them to meet
so they go ahead and they meet but for
once in my life i had the privilege of
vetoing the president of the united
states
now he instead though broke made it
essential he goes
the extra mile without no thought of
what he might receive for his services
in other words he didn't charge the
president of the united states
a penny to work for him this is all
despite the fact that napoleon hill's
life up to this point
has been solely for the purpose of
accumulating riches but when it comes to
the president
he doesn't want to impose other features
of this
incredible man's life is that apparently
later on
after woodrow wilson had moved out of
the white house he got to know another
president
franklin delano roosevelt apparently
although his record
of a real relationship proof is
surprisingly scant according to his
biographers
but in conversations and in some of his
papers he'll sometimes claim to have
coined the historic remark
we have nothing to fear but fear itself
and claim to have written a number of
roosevelt's fireside chats that's right
guys
while not meeting with the billionaire
business magnate
andrew carnegie he was busy consoling
america consoling america and making
sure that everyone felt okay
by drafting the fireside chats according
to napoleon hill
he supplied the president with a steady
stream of suggestions for topics
and fully aware of his own powers of
persuasion he was never bashful about
supplying a script
that would help the president make his
point
oh the original fake guru guys
this man is claiming to have mentored
two presidents i mean at this point he's
mentoring them
and he personally got self-selected by
by andrew carnegie
to be plucked from poverty and to be
suddenly made
the number one writer what a lucky guy
i've gotta say
as wilson's suddenly deciding whether he
should uh
have an armistice for germany and
napoleon hills in the room
and the first person he read the decoded
message to was of course
napoleon hill which wilson's face turned
white as snow
when he finished reading he handed the
document to napoleon hill that's right
top secret decoded information who do
you give it to
napoleon hill you leave it with that
person apparently the president was gone
for 15 minutes when he returned he
handed me a couple of sheets of paper on
which he had written his reply to
the germans which ended with three
questions related to the terms of the
armistice
after i read his reply he asked if
napoleon hill
had any suggestions to add to it hey
napoleon would you like to help
in world war one huh
now if all of this is starting to sound
increasingly improbable
and it seems like the whole thing is
made up just wait the story
is just beginning because napoleon hill
also faked being an attorney at law
i don't know if you guys can see that he
wrote that uh he's napoleon
napoleon hill attorney at law michigan
avenue
his own biographers who at this point
have found it credulous
and included as fact that he has been an
advisor
to woodrow wilson and fdr they call this
a highly exaggerated claim aka
a lie
but all of this pales in comparison
to the fake college this man set up
that's right napoleon hill not only
started the fake testimonials the fake
mentorships
you know just lying about who you met
lying about their advice
he also coined something else the
original course
guys this is i'm serious you guys know
thinking grow rich but you guys don't
know
the automobile college of washington
where he supposedly
trained chauffeurs and car owners to
drive and prepare mechanics
told assembly line jobs in automobile
plants that's how his biographers
talk about it now and this is well borne
out
in the actual newspaper clippings that
this man was the president of the
automobile college of washington
but what his biographers coincidentally
don't mention
is this this is an
old-school coffeezilla back before
back before uh coffeezilla existed this
is the original thing
some guy wrote pointing the easy route
to get rich quick land
which was an expose on napoleon hill
i'm not even lying this man during his
life was exposed
for running a fake course he got zilla
look at this okay
i'll only read you the most important
parts okay
so they make fun of the fact uh that
they call this the greatest school of
expert automobile engineering
in the united states does that not sound
like a caleb maddox line
the greatest opportunity of our era
literally nothing has changed
and that's the i really believe that the
yta method is the greatest opportunity
of our era additionally this thing says
the catalog ought to be worth its weight
in gold to the
dyspeptic for there's a good laugh on
every page which is
you know old town speak for this guy
is a clown and they're talking about the
automobile college of washington
apparently the whole scheme was a big
plan to get free labor
from college students so you would pay
in and they would get free labor how it
worked
is you'd go into the school and while
training you you worked for them
you paid to be trained while you worked
for them and they had partnered with
like an automobile manufacturer
and supposedly at the end you were
supposed to get the sales job where you
could make you know thousands of dollars
at the time
none of that was true see napoleon hill
was also the first person to uh make big
income claims
our course prepares you to earn 4 800
a year or more briefly the plan is all
that those who attend and become a
student of this college
will get a job in this college become
sales agents guys you can be a high
ticket closer for napoleon hill see he
was the first one
to do it right and why am i showing you
all of this why are we going through so
much detail
well guys you might have been mystified
before
when somebody who has as good of a
reputation as napoleon hill
could produce such sleaze bags as people
like you know
your locks of the world you're uh tai
lopez's of the world how
how does that square away but when you
actually look at napoleon hill's life
and then you look at the life of people
who are inspired by them you go oh yeah
they're the same person this guy used
the tactics that modern day
fake business gurus are using before it
was ever a thing and then he wrote their
bible
are we really surprised but wait guys
there's more
there's also a multi-level marketing
side to this whole whole scheme and by
the way remember this is a paper
from back in the day this is all
historical okay so i'm not making any of
this stuff
up it's all factually either in napoleon
hill's biography
newspaper clippings andrew carnegie's
biography so don't get mad at me this is
not me saying it
it's like the fault of everyone who's
read napoleon hill up to this point and
never bothered to look
any further than simply think and grow
rich
now not only does napoleon hill do all
of that he also
made it an mlm this college he says the
very day you enroll
you may begin to send this to the names
of young men who you might be
you you think might be interested in our
course
and you got commissions for it guys
[Music]
i can't stand this this man is a con man
and he says oh you're gonna pay for your
course several times over
in this manner now this author of course
points out that if everyone did this
then of course
the entire district of columbia would
soon be required for the campus
obviously this stuff grows exponentially
so these people
back in the day back in the 1900s
realized this guy was a con man
but through the power of just kind of
whitewashing history little by little
people forget that these things exist
this man has managed to make
a reputation for himself of being some
genius in business in reality
even by his biographer's account who are
super generous with him who believe all
his stupid claims he was constantly
broke
constantly in debt even went to jail oh
yeah i forgot about that did i tell you
that he went to jail for a stock scheme
which is why he got arrested
for blue sky stuff which is in illinois
law about unlicensed securities
he was arrested and released and you
know what his excuse was
hill claimed that he was simply a
forceful
writer guys let me stop for a second and
just ask you have you heard that before
have you ever heard a marketer who i'm
calling a fake guru go hey i just like
to
aggressively market you know so what i
say you're gonna make a million dollars
it's just aggressive marketing
this is where it all comes from this is
why
again he's at the center of the board
this man
is the con men of all khan men and
nobody
knows it actually there's one great
article about this
uh paleofuture.gizmodo.com incredible
article i'll link it below
a lot of the stuff you're seeing here is
from that although i went and hunted up
the sources myself
just to make sure they were legit but
this is why he's at the very center
because despite maintaining an attitude
and a reputation of perfection
the truth about napoleon hill is that is
that he lied about
who he was talking to he lied about who
he was being mentored by
he invented wild claims he invented
the first mlm pos i don't know if that's
the first mlm but it's one of the first
mlms ever
he invented a course like every move
that you see of the modern guru it's all
taken from napoleon hill he's the king
he's on top
and he's on top for a reason because
damn
he was ahead of his time i mean let me
be very real with you and the truth
about him is just really not known
people think he's some savant some
genius who talked to the great minds of
america
but the truth is they never knew him
they never heard of this guy
which can be proven by the fact if you
read andrew carnegie who's written his
own books he didn't need someone to
write them for him
they're so wildly different than
napoleon hill napoleon hill's andrew
carnegie and the real andrew carnegie
are two completely different people one
is some
self-help person with a bunch of puff
and fluff the other is like a practical
businessman who talks like a businessman
who understands competition
who understands market forces who
understands that not everything is just
about
your mindset right so what do we make of
the napoleon
hill story now that it's all out there
well
it's interesting just like i think
napoleon hill was sort of
the original guru i think we can learn a
lot of lessons
from both his successes and his failures
because obviously
his fraud was very successful because
millions of people have bought his books
a million millions of people have bought
into this idea that he was
you know some oracle of the rich and
famous
but the truth is when he died he died
most people suspect penniless he had
been bankrupt many times he had been run
out of towns
he said there was an attempted
assassination on his life
fraud accusations of fraud it all just
follows the familiar path
of our confidence men they achieve a
little bit of success because
scams do but ultimately they're
constantly undone by their own design he
was constantly
spending too much money spending more
money than he could afford chased by
creditors
this man is not someone you want to look
up to even though
on the outside all that glitters is gold
the truth
is that something was rotting at the
heart of napoleon hill's story
you know i know that this might seem
weird for me to say at the very end of
all this but i do
think there's good things in think and
grow rich
about positive thinking about goal
setting but the problem is
that think and grow rich takes it too
far it makes it into some
gospel of success that positive thinking
is all that you need that you don't need
luck that you don't need talent that any
person can just wish themselves into a
trillion dollars and if you don't have
that trillion dollars yet
well you just must not be thinking about
it enough you must not be
desiring it enough that is completely
ridiculous and leads to a
toxic system of punishment for people
who haven't achieved
their dreams as my friend james johnny
would later say
in his series on the law of attraction
so i'm not saying
throw out your book of think and grow
rich if you want to keep it if it helps
you
hey i think that's fine but you should
know who napoleon hill
was you should know what the end of his
life looked like
and you should know who he really talked
to and who he really didn't
thanks for watching and i'll see you in
the next one
you